goo トゥディ
皆さんは日本における高齢冠水がどうなっ
ているかご存じでしょうか
これは内閣府がまとめた高齢社会白書の
グラフになります
2015年現在日本の総人口はピークを
迎えつつあります
今後世の中で言われているように少子化が
進み
年々年を追うごとに日本の総人口というの
は減少に辿っていきます
そして40年後
2055年には65歳以上という高齢者の
占める割合が全日本の人口の約40%にし
ベルまで付てしまいますつまり今我々の
世代が40年号
まさにこの高齢者というところにいること
になります
一方
第一次産業農林水産業と呼ばれる分野に
従事している人の数はどうなっているか皆
さんご存知でしょうか
高齢者としているにも関わらず
第1次産業に従事する人の人数は年々低下
の1等をたどっています
全産業に占める第一次産業の割合はなんと
3.6%しかないというつくなさんはが今
の状況だと言えます
このような状況で第1次産業農林水産業と
いうものは日本からなくなってしまうの
でしょうか
こちらは農林水産省のまとめた
生産農業所得統計というグラフです
上に締めさせていただきましたのは農業が
産み出そうかね農業総産出額のグラフと
なります
農業従事者の数が減少しているのもあり
農業が創出する総産出額というものも年連
減少しています
そのため農業に従事している農業従事者の
所得
生産農業所得というものも年々低下の1等
をたどっているということがわかると思い
ます
過酷な農作業
収入も不安定かもしれない
このようなイメージの強い農業に
堅実な道を歩もうとする若者はあえて
選ぼうとするでしょうか
そのため高齢化の進行はますます住み農業
従事者は減少
耕作放棄地も増加
こういった悪循環が今の日本の増強を表し
ているのではないかと感じます
では日本の第一次産業の将来は本当に悲観
すべきことばかりだと思いますか
私はそんなことはないと感じています
現在私どもの世代は農業に従事しており
ませんが
企業戦士として夜遅くまでに家や仕事を
やってくれているという事実があります
そして自然に触れながら自分のペースと
採用で仕事ができる農業というものにある
意味憧れというものを抱いているそういう
人もいるかもしれません
また情報通信技術を駆使して生産方法の
工夫や改善をすることで収穫規模や収益性
を拡大できるのではないか
そういう可能性を感じたりします
第1次産業が生産する特産物を第1次産業
によって高い付加価値をつけ
ブランド化を進め
そして第3次産業の流通と販売に効果的に
結びつけることが出来れば1カケルに
かけるさんが6になるように第6次産業化
つまり農業のそう産業化というものが実現
できるのではないかと考えています
もちろんここには食品衛生や理数管理への
責任といった問題が発生することはあり
ます
ただし超高齢化社会を迎えるという事実上
に対しあまり悲観的なことばかり考えて
いるわけにもいかないのかなというのが
正直なところです皆さんは日本の植物構造
という技術をご存知でしょうか
この中でも植物構造という技術に関与され
ている方が吹くなか等でいるかもしれませ
ん
google の画像検索で植物構造と
いうキーワードを検索するとこのような
結果が得られます
植物工場には大きく分けて2つの種類が
あって
太陽光を利用した太陽光利用型植物構造と
いうものと led や蛍光灯を利用して
構造のような形で生産する
人工光利用型植物構造というものがあり
ます
実際に大手機械メーカー等は led や
蛍光灯を用い
工場のクリーンルームのようなところを
街道することによってレタスやハモの植物
そういったものを生産し販売するという
授業を始めています
つまり先ほどご紹介したような農業のそう
産業化6次産業化というものは着々と進ん
でいるという事実がうかがえます
では世界はどうでしょうか
これはコロンビア大学のディクソンで
ポミエ教授が提唱するバーチカルファーム
というコンセプトになります
日本語に訳すと垂直の業というふうに翻訳
することができます
このコンセプトは都市圏の土地の有効活用
の一案として提案されています
このような1つの建物の中で家畜を育てる
だけでなく植物を育て刃物だけでなく果物
まで育てる
そしてそこで生産された野菜や肉を1回の
スーパーで販売するという建物を建て木
循環型の農業を実現してしまおうという
構想です
もしこのような都市部で垂直農業という
ものが実現できたとしたら
輸送費の大幅な削減ができるだけでなく
新たな雇用を創出
生活との調和
明るい未来が想像できるのではないかと
感じます
もちろんこんな世界を実現するには経済的
な問題エネルギー消費効率の問題
さまざまな課題があります
ですがこのコンセプトをもとにデザイナー
の方々が描いたこの絵を見させていただく
と私も頭の片隅にこんな世界がいつか本当
に作ることができないのかということを
想像しながら日夜研究に明け暮れていると
いう状況です
じゃあここから私の研究の話に入りたいと
思います
皆さんは植物の成長がどのような仕組みに
よって行われているか覚えてますか
実はこれは小学校4年生の理科の教科書に
載っています
植物は葉の表で光合成を行い葉の裏で嬢
さんを行って成長していきます
高剛性というのは太陽の光エネルギーを
用いて大気中の co2と根から吸収した
水から有機物を合成する仕組みです
一方日が当たり始めると葉の裏から和尚
さんが始まってねから水や養分を吸収し
植物の全体に輸送が始まります
ではこの植物の成長を図るにはどうしたら
いいでしょうか
植物の成長を図ることができれば植物の
生育状態をコントロールできるかもしれ
ません
私はこの素朴な疑問に対し
植物の成長は光合成と増産に関係する
高剛性と嬢さんは植物が持つ葉っぱにを
含まれる成分によって行われる
ということは植物の葉がどれぐらい茂って
いるのかということを間接的にでも継続
することができれば
植物の成長を図ることができるのではない
かと考えました
そして今日ここで持ってきた物がそのため
に研究開発したものになります
こちらは無線で計測できる無線散乱光
センサーと呼ばれるものです
植物の成長は光合成東條さんつまり葉っぱ
がどれだけ茂っているかということに関係
があります
葉っぱはしげれば茂ほど植物体の中の状態
は暗くなります
それは幅太陽の光が当たるように茂って
いくからです
ですから私はこの乾電池で駆動する無線で
データを計測できるこういったものを開発
することによって
植物の上と植物の中で2か所で計測する
ことで
植物の明るさの違いというものを計測する
ことができるのではないかと考えました
これによって同時に気温と湿度明るさ
そういったものを計測できるのですが
嬢さんの量光合成の量というものを
葉っぱの市販モードと言われる茂りぐらい
から想像することができるのではないかと
考えています
一方もう一つ重要になる植物の吸収する水
と養分です
こちらも水耕栽培の植物に限れば
宮駅タンクの中の水の量を計測すればどれ
だけの量の溝井植物が吸収しているのか
想像することができるかもしれません
そしてその宮駅タンクの中の水の溶液の
濃度を計測すればどれだけの濃度の養分が
水と一緒に吸収されたのかこちらも間接的
に計算することができるかもしれません
我々はこのようなセンサーを多数開発する
ことによって同時に多数の気温湿度明るさ
をして水溶液濃度というものを計測できる
環境を構築しましたそして実際にそれらの
データと研究室で事前に計測しておいた
そのデータ系列との組み合わせでわかる
実際植物の養分吸収量というものの紐付け
を行い
コンピューターに大量のデータの学習を
行っています
そして現在の気温や湿度水濃度との像たい
からこれまでの過去のデータから
もっともらしい養分の吸収量というものを
コンピューターに推測させることができ
ないかという課題にチャレンジしています
これによって篤農家と呼ばれる農業の
プロフェッショナルが経験や勘で実現して
いるノウハウをコンピューターに再現さ
せることができないかそういう
プロジェクトです
ただここで一つ気になることがあります
それはコンピューターに学習させるべく
経験値とも呼べる学習データ量は多ければ
多いほど良いのであろうかということです
多ければ多いほどそれを収集するための
労力が時間が大変になります
そこで我々はアメダスのオープンデータを
用いてコンピューターに学習させるデータ
の量が3年分のデータを利用してその
データとコンピューターの予測するデータ
の誤差がどのように変化するのかという
分析を行いました
日本の気候は縦に長いということもあり
札幌東京浜松那覇といった4地域を代表に
とって学習するデータの量を最大3年分の
増加させることで誤差がどのように変化
するのかという分析を行いました
ここで興味深いのは那覇に関しては学習
データが多ければ多いほど誤差というもの
は小さくなったにも関わらず
札幌や東京ハマスといったエリアではどこ
に札幌では学習させればさせるだけ良く
なるということもなく
実は8ヶ月ぐらいデータを学習させる
ぐらいが一番精度が良かったというそう
いう系彼が分かりました
つまりここで言えるのはコンピューターに
学習させるデータの量には適切な量という
ものがあるのではないか
そういう仮説を立てました
しかし人間がそれぞれの地域のデータを
コンピューターに学習させ
どれくらいのデータが最も良いのかという
ことをいちいち確認していたのではキリが
ありません
そこで私は一つの方法を思いつきました
これはコンピューターが大量のデータの中
から様々なデータを重出しその抽出した
データから複数の異なる予測モデルを構築
して予測をし続けるというモデルになり
ます
みなさん明日の朝の7時半の気温を何度に
なるか想像してみてください
多分人によってこの創造の仕方というのは
変わってくると思います
たとえばある人は今は春なので春の預け方
の温度は大体これぐらいかなぁとを張ると
いうことをキーワードに予測するかもしれ
ません
またある人は最近の朝の温度データという
ものをベースに大体こういうふうに推移し
てるんだったらしたもこれくらいの温度に
なるだろうと予測する人もいるかもしれ
ません
また理系で統計に長けた人がいればですね
過去の状況を分析して今と同じような
データだけを抽出しそのデータから明日の
温度を予測するっていうことができれば
より正確な温度予測できるのではないかと
考える人もいるかもしれません
いずれにせよ明日の朝になれば政界の
データが分かります
ですのでその正解がわかった時点で
どのような学習モデルを使って予測したの
が一番精度が良いのかが分かります
ですからそのモデルを使ってしばらく予測
をし続けるというようなアルゴリズムに
なります
もし何日か経ってその予測モデルが誤差
大きく生じるような状況になったらまた
同じような複数のモデルをくせいせいし
予測し直すということを繰り返す
これをコンピューターが自動的に実行
できるような仕組みを考えました
私はこのアルゴリズムにスライディング
犬童ベース support vector
リグレッションという名前をつけました
今日はせっかくこの場に皆さん集まって
いただきましたからスライディング犬童
ベース support vector
レグれっしょんという名前だけは覚えて
帰って頂ければと思います
そして私どもは磐田にある静岡県の農林
技術研究所というところで実証実験を進め
ています
実際にこちらの無線散乱光センサーを用い
て環境情報を収集し大量の環境庁方から
先ほどの sws vr を用いて植物の
窒素吸収量6時間後に地質をどれくらい
吸収しているのかということを
コンピューターに予測させていますそして
その予測結果に基づく窒息供給営業という
ものをすることによってか不足のない宮駅
制御を実現しています
なぜか不足の代休役声優が重要かといい
ますと
トマトのような栽培の場合
溶液を投入すれば果実の肥大化速度という
ものは促進されます
しかし彼はの成長よりも果実の促進速度が
速くなってしまうと皮が破れてしまい
売り物にならなくなってしまいますです
から多すぎてもいけない好きなすぎても
いけないか不足のない宮駅制御というもの
が重要になってきますこれがこの冬に行わ
れた実証実験の結果のグラフの一つです
黒いグラフは実際に植物が吸収したと思わ
れるチェスト吸収量を表しています
赤いグラフは我々のアルゴリズムで植物が
これだけ吸収するだろうと予測された値に
なります
11月26日
最初に構築した予測モデルで黒いグラフと
赤いグラフはだいたい同じぐらいのところ
を推しています
しかししばらく時間が経つにつれて玄人
赤い線は大きくずれが生じてきています
そして20dec 頃
コンピューターが自動的に再構築する必要
があると判断しモデルの再構築を行いまし
た
その後は植物の吸収している量と予測制御
の量はだいたい同じくらいの値を推して
制御することができるようになっています
この結果から言えることはコンピューター
が人間のノウハウをある意味再現可能に
なりつつあるという事実を示していると
言えます
最初に私は超高齢化社会を迎えることを
悲観的に考えるべきではないと言いました
現在我々が取り組んでいるような過酷な
現場のネットワーク化
ノウハウの再現の可能性
これらを増法通信技術を駆使してさまざま
な産業や人との連携したそう産業化という
ことを実現できる可能性があると考えてい
ます発想は素人でしたが close 的
に実行することが出来れば皆さんと一緒に
明るい未来を創世できるのではないかその
ように私は館されていますぜひ皆さんで
明るい未来を創生していければと思ってい
ます
今日はどうもありがとうございました